effectivement j'ai toujours été
passionné par ce qui est digital et puis
la relation client et j'ai eu cette
chance-là de trouver justement une
alternance où j'avais de la vente à
distance et où c'était digital et et
justement si vous me permettez
j'aimerais vous raconter mon histoire
mais leur demain soir elle est l
incroyable parce que tu as eu un avc à
la naissance c'est ça tout à fait kita
il m'a fallu audité de l'oreille ouais
c'est ça qui m'a mis une surdité à
l'oreille droite qui m'a privé
partiellement de mon bras gauche et de
ma jambe gauche
mais quand je suis arrivé il ya une
vingtaine d'années dans ce monde j'ai eu
deux handicaps jument handicap physique
avec tout ce qui s'ensuit les kinés les
médecins les chirurgiens les
ergothérapeutes etc
et j'ai eu la difficulté de me dire dans
ce monde je vais avoir beaucoup plus de
mal à me faire ma place dans le monde
professionnel ou dans la vie de tous les
jours parce que ici sur mon front il y
aura marqué personnes en situation de
handicap a évité à fuir c'est ce qui se
passe c'est ce qui s'est passé pendant
pas mal d'années j'ai eu j'ai été
soutenu j'ai été j'ai été aidé par ma
famille mes proches mais ça a été très
difficile et justement je me permets mon
grand père n'est malheureusement plus de
ce monde il est parti à cause de cette
maladie que ce que cette épidémie
convient en ce moment et il m'a souvent
répété cette phrase et je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui elle prend tout son sens
il m'a dit un jour tu parleras et on
t'écoutera et regardez-les cette fierté
pour toi d'être ici c'est pas une fierté
c'est un immense honneur et je sais que
de là où il est il doit être fier de moi
oui
je voulais juste vous expliquer quand
j'ai eu mon bac
moi je voulais m'arrêter parce que parce
que c'était trop difficile on demander
trop de choses et j'avais du mal j'ai dû
passer à une étape dans ma vie où on a
clairement dit à moi et à ma mère votre
fils n'aura jamais mieux que les
encouragements à cause de ces
difficultés ont marre abc on m'a mis
dans une case sans savoir ce que je
valais vraiment ans au lycée je suis
arrivé au lycée et jusqu'à la fin de ma
terminale j'ai eu les félicitations aux
trois trimestres et j'ai obtenu mon bac
avec mention bien et juste fait mon père
mon père qui est un homme extraordinaire
m'a dit vaut mieux que tu es un bagage
en plus tu perds rien tu perds rien
avoir en plus sur son cv et c'est ce qui
va faire que que plus tard tu auras tu
aura l'opportunité de rentrer dans la
boîte que tu veux et et de demander ce
que toi tu veux et je voudrais juste
terminée en leur rendant hommage
papa maman je sais que je vais parler au
nom de mon frère et ma soeur
tiens à vous remercier pour tout ce que
vous avez fait pour nous et sachez que
si on n'est pas les meilleurs enfants du
monde et pas vous vous êtes des parents
extraordinaire et je suis très heureux
des taux de 6 alors on aura besoin de
mouchoirs soir aussi max et aujourd'hui
je sais donc tenté en bts et tu as
trouvé une alternance chez blue link
grâce au programme justement un jeune
une solution comment tu as connu ce
programme en fait c'est très simple j'ai
directement contacté bluelink en fait
lors de mon entretien j'ai pu leur
expliquer ma situation ce que je voulais
faire mes projets ma personnalité mes
qualités et mes compétences leur ont
beaucoup plu et ils se sont eux
rapprochés de l'agefi qui leur a parlé
de ce projet et ils se sont renseignés
pour que pour mon cursus scolaire donc
ma formation
une semaine en entreprise et une semaine
en formation donc à l'école je puisse
avoir un système adapté c'est à dire une
avs dans ce qu'ils ne savent pas c'est
une personne qui qui nous aide et nous
soutient dans les cours comme dans les
examens à écrire pour nous et nous
risquons nous expliquer ce qu'on n'a pas
compris et j'en profite d'ailleurs pour
remercier mon avis est ce que j'ai
depuis huit ans qui m'a soutenu jusqu'au
bout et m'a toujours dit qu'elle me
mettrai le plus possible en hauteur et
vers le sommet donc je tiens à te
remercier nadia situe si tu nous
regardes on embrasse la dia
je te sens aujourd'hui
oui je suis heureux parce que qui est à
quel âge tu as 20 ans pile après c'est
ça je te sors et rouge de son plein
d'ambition et ça ça fait plaisir c'est
pour ça qu'on voulait commencer
l'émission vraiment pas par du positif
comme ça c'est vrai que max quand on le
voit il donne et on se dit et c'est ce
qui nous donne une gt gt mal parti et
s'est donné les moyens de réussir et je
n'avais pas le choix je n'avais pas le
choix c'était c'était soit je me relever
et je prenais des coups et j'encaissais
soit ce soit je me laissais mon fiancé
et gg mes parents ont très vite mis
savoir la tête mais c'est eux qui m'ont
porté au début en me disant c'est hors
de question que tu te jeter d'un moment
tu t'es dit j'y arriverai jamais ou
jamais c'est vrai qu'il ya des périodes
où je me suis dit j'y arriverai jamais
ouais tu es parents il tourne et ont
soutenu la six a par exemple
malheureusement à cause du confinement
on était chez nous en courant vision
j'avais pas mon avs j'avais pas les
mêmes soutient que j'ai en cours j'étais
chez moi et j'ai regardé ma mère je lui
dis maman je veux arrêter j'en peux plus
je suis arrivé à une période où la
actuellement je suis en train de passer
mes examens
j'ai regardé ma main en lui disant mais
je me reconnais plus personnellement je
ne suis plus moi même je ne je n'y
arrive plus il ya des choses que je ne
comprends pas et j'y suis je veux quand
même y aller parce que mes parents me
me redonne la raison de me dire mais va
au moins au bout juste pour ne pas avoir
ni de regret ni de remords et je vais
aller au bout et je vais tout faire pour
l'obtenir
thibault guily au commissaire à l'emploi
et il y avait deux bandes ministre du
travail quand on entend son dit qu'on
commence vraiment par ces témoignages
sont à voir le témoignage de sun du judo
tic qui est une magnifique réussite on a
envie voilà que ce soir aussi de porter
un message d'espoir pour les jeunes
moi je trouve vraiment que ton
témoignage il votre témoignage est très
très entraînants présent grâce à la
ministre tutoie pourtant non mais c'est
très impressionnant la façon dont alors
tu t'es accroché la volonté que tu as
fait preuve et je pense que c'est
important aussi de dire que les parents
ont été derrière toi et ton fait
confiance j'ai eu cette chance là c'est
pas donné à tout le monde mais c'est
vrai que j'ai eu cette chance là et ils
le savent et j'en suis énormément
reconnaissant
thibault est peut-être mais peut-être je
pense que ce qui est très important
c'est que l'alu cursus dans lequel tu
t'es engagé
l'apprentissage c'est vraiment quelque
chose qu'on veut encourager ça veut dire
se former en étant en partie en
formation mais aussi en étant en
entreprise donc on apprend un métier on
découvre l'entreprise
on a une rémunération et puis souvent au
décroche un job à la clé et moi je suis
très heureuse que les aides qu'on a mis
en place parce que c'est des êtres qui
sont très incitative pour les
entreprises un ses 8000 euros quand on
embauche un apprenti mais que ça
permette que tu puisse continuer tes
études comme tu comme tu es en train de
faire